my knowledge of Chanukah is the Disney
Channel movie fulcrum miracle what I
know vaguely about the story I learned
from the Rugrats
I know that there's a menorah
you have to have letters the nation
eh-eh-eh you and I K tonic a.k.a
Hanukkah celebrates um was it when they
were like crossing the Red Sea they only
have like a little bit of oil and
through the miracle of the Lord that oil
lasted eight nights that's why
everything is fried I think and why
potato pancakes other well in my life oh
my god I don't even know how many days
it is it's like seven days right I think
it's eight days of Hanukkah
so there are 12 candles and a menorah
there are nine candles on the menorah
because I think it's like one for every
day of the week because there's one for
every night and then there's the one
master candle that you use to light all
of the other ones
what's a dreidel I don't know don't know
what it means
dreidels are big spoons that Jewish
people use to collect matzo balls out of
the pot you spin the dreidel and then
when it falls on you like have to do
what it says when you get chocolate
coins if you win you win or you lose or
you take another turn or you take the
other guy's coins I just remember like
Jewish friends getting presents like all
week everybody drinks Manischewitz maybe
they have like a Hanukkah party at the
end of it I sit around a circle and they
play the guitar and I think they leave a
seat open for Elijah and Adam Sandler is
leading the ceremony
you